hi
steve here i just had an idea
you know i wonder if
if those of us who are members of of
link if we would sit down every now and
again and just
throw together some thoughts so
talk about what we just did and share
that with people who are learning our
language so here i am it's a saturday
um my wife and i had a slow breakfast i
like to make the coffee on our espresso
machine
then we went off and played some golf
then we came back home my wife made
dinner we had uh we thought out a bit of
salmon which we ate raw we grated some
ginger on top sprinkled some olive oil
had it with wasabi and
soy sauce
and then she made a chicken and a cumin
and whatever type of thing and and had a
little sauce for that and we had some
salad with it a little bit of wine
and then i cleaned up
well my wife played the piano and
now i'm settling down to read a book
um
yeah
that's what i'm doing right now i wonder
if it would be an interesting thing to
have different people
uh talk in their own language about what
they're doing and just send that to
people within our community who are
learning that language they'll be
interested in your views bye for now